an animated Stargate movie
have I lost my mind
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
so in a recent video while I was talking
about the increasingly likely
possibility that Warner Brothers might
end up actually producing the new
Stargate franchise we're expecting to be
announced soon I suggested that Amazon
MGM partnering up with Warner Brothers
did open up an interesting possibility
the possibility of an animated movie now
Warner Brothers is currently producing
an animated movie of Babylon 5. they're
setting it just a couple of years after
the series ended they have replaced
several of the actors that have passed
away sadly with other actors I should
say with the family of the original
actor's permission and obviously all of
the other actors have aged quite a lot
so it was not possible to do a live
action project so they've done it using
animation I've seen the trailer I've put
it on my channel a couple of days ago
and it looks pretty cool Warner Brothers
are actually also already partnering
with Amazon to produce the new Lord of
the Rings animated movie The War of the
royal Rim I hope I'm saying that right
Harris is going to be angry if I said it
wrong and stormy might actually get jump
in a plane and come across and kill me
so
so for me actually that is a really big
indicator already that Amazon is more
than willing to work with Warner
Brothers animation
it should also be said that Warner
Brothers animation have been making the
straight to DVD straight to streaming
movies for a long time for DC and
generally speaking they've been the best
DC stuff done now I didn't get a lot of
comments saying no animation no I want
live action I don't want anything
animated
and I completely get you at no point am
I saying that any animated project would
replace anything that could be done with
live action I still thoroughly expect
straight to cinema live action movies
and of course a bunch of series
hopefully that will follow
but what I am saying is if Amazon do
decide to partner with Warner Brothers
like I kind of I'm getting to the point
where I almost expected to happen now
then there is this possibility with
Warner Brothers animation now obviously
there are certain projects that could be
done that would be difficult to do with
live action
say for example if you wanted to do
something that was maybe set in and
around the early sg1 series you wouldn't
be able to have General Hammond in it
Donis Davis sadly passed away in 2008
and if you wanted to do a project based
in around the sg1 series his passing
really does leave a massive gaping hole
now JMS when he did The Babylon 5 movie
insisted that the original actus
families must agree before he recast
them I would want Amazon MGM Warner
Brothers to do exactly the same and get
Donis Davey's family to actually agree
to do this but if they did we could get
General Hammond back in Stargate the
other obvious project we're doing in sg1
Project is that the actors have aged
quite a bit now Richard Dean Anderson
has said he might not want to actually
come back to that he's basically retired
but he might be willing for a decent
paycheck to do an animated project
because
far less time consuming
you only go in for a few days here and
there do the voice and then go home
there's no need for hours of makeup
hours of this waiting for sets to get
set up blah blah blah it's far less time
consuming for actors now I actually
don't think that's a major problem for
somebody like Amanda Tapping or Michael
Shanks or the rest of many of the actors
but they've still aged
really it's only been Browder that looks
exactly the same that guy must be a
vampire he actually hasn't aged at all
Michael Shanks could maybe get away with
it Maybe
but if you wanted to do a project that
may be filled in a few of the gaps or
told some sort of story that might lead
into the new projects
that was based in and around previous
sg1 episodes doing it animated is the
only way to do it Cliff Simon also sadly
passed away and his character of Lord
Bal was one of my favorites I would love
to see more stuff with that character
again if his family agreed there is
another big project though that a lot of
people want to see that I can't help but
Wonder would only be possible if it's
done via animation
the SGU conclusion now we've talked
about that a lot on this channel and it
is a very popular idea that we want the
Stargate Universe storyline to get a
conclusion so it's been just over 12
years since Stargate Universe ended the
actors haven't aged terribly but you
could maybe say that everyone's still in
stasis that you know Eli
I'm having a lot of food so we slimmed
down quite a bit but the Eli has
survived that long on his own it's not
beyond the Realms of possibility and
that for some reason Eli has to trigger
the stasis parts and bring everybody
back and then they somehow save the
Destiny save themselves
it would be expensive it would require
bringing an awful lot of actors back you
would have to maybe explain the aging
process a little bit but you could say a
couple of the stasis spots fail
um you know there are ways around it but
would they invest that time and money in
a project that
is a little bit controversial
not everybody within the Gators
Community loved Stargate Universe
I did a live video literally yesterday
talking about this how I actually found
SGU a little boring I said it was
getting better don't get me wrong and if
we'd have gone into a third fourth fifth
season I'd have probably ended up loving
this show as much as I loved sg1 and SGA
but the first season was mind-numbingly
boring and I think most Gators
would admit that it's their third
favorite there are people out there that
think it's the best sci-fi ever made
don't get me wrong but I think it's fair
to say most datas would say it's their
third favor to the three
so
would Amazon and MGM really invest the
time and the money to bring back the
third most popular of the franchises
when there are other options
I suspect not
but
an animated project is way cheaper way
quicker and way easier to do so what you
could do is have an SGU animated movie
something that fills the Gap something
that you know explains how a lot of
those crew could then return to other
projects in live action I've already
told you that I'm being told that Robert
Carlisle has already been approached
about potentially returning for one of
the movies so how can you do that unless
we know what happens with an SGU
an animated movie might be the way to do
that and it will just be less of a risk
for MGM and Amazon
now Gators even me would go nuts for it
I would love a conclusion to SGU because
I hate that string just floating out
there I want it to be tied off
but also it could be a great opportunity
to give us something maybe before the
cinematic movies released because an
animated movie could be done much
quicker and I have to admit as well I
have to say the Babylon 5 animated movie
was done very very quietly we didn't
know that it had been done
until actually a couple of months ago
and it's released like next month
so we only found out they've done that
three months before its release
been talking about it and said it was in
the can around Christmas so obviously he
wrote it but they were able to keep that
very very quiet you couldn't keep a big
cinematic movie quite like that you just
couldn't
so
they could do an animated movie very
quickly it could be released before the
Cinematic movie and it could tell us a
lot of the story that we need to know
before the Cinematic movie it could set
up all of those foundations
for the Cinematic release
to me it just seems like a no-brainer
and I'm going to repeat again because
people are going to jump in the comments
and say this but not to replace anything
that can be done live action
to give us some more
and it would be grown up adult animation
it wouldn't be for kids Babylon 5 the
road home is a hundred percent not made
for kids I think it's got a 12a rating
here it's got a PG-13 rating in the
United States
um it's not you know a manga 18 Gore
Fest by any stretch of the imagination
but also it's been made for Babylon 5
fans it's not been made for kids another
really hardcore sci-fi fans under the
age of 20 even know what Babylon 5 is
this project this animated movie was
made for 40 somethings
that's just the way it is as I say there
are lots of projects that would be
either just too expensive too difficult
or just downright impossible to do using
live action but if Amazon really do
partner with Warner Brothers
to make the Stargate series
the animation wing of Warner Brothers
really does give us an interesting
possibility to fill in some of those
gaps with animated projects
so get into the comments and tell me
what you think have I won you over
have I argued this well enough that even
if you hate animation that you can at
least see where I'm coming from
actually would animated project be
something you would really look forward
to because of the reasons I've described
or is it animation no under any
circumstances leave it alone and
particularly bringing characters back
that their actors have passed away
even if the families agree
is that a bit of a problem
I would argue it's better than recasting
them but
yeah
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe and hit all the buttons you
know what to do also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where you can get to see most of our new
videos Premiere first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports a channel and you get a free
gift after a couple of months you get to
see them without the adverts
as always please stay safe guys and I'll
see you next time
foreign